Abby everyone always says bagels are
unhealthy but how can you use them as a
hunger crushing combo oh I got a really
great hack for this let me show you
we're gonna make an air fryer omelette
stuffed Bagel first I'm just going to
scramble up a little egg here
add in a little bell pepper steamed
broccoli a little salt a little pep then
I'm gonna take my bagel and I'm gonna
make a little moat I've got a little
avocado I'm just going to smash as kind
of like a little spread down on the
bottom there and then we're just going
to carefully put our egg into the hole
top it off with a little cheese action
and let's pop it into our air fryer for
about five minutes tell me this is not
super fun and you can switch it up based
on what you've got in your fridge we got
protein on our eggs healthy fats in the
avocado plus some cheese and some Fiber
in the bagel and the veg is it a bagel
is it a sandwich I don't know all I know
is that it's tasty as
mmm